what flavors of catastrophic risk
are we talking about here what's your
favorite flavor in terms of ice cream
so mine is coconut nobody seems to like
coconut ice cream
so ice cream aside
what's uh what are you most worried
about if there's a catastrophic risk
that will help us kind of um
make concrete the the the discussion
we're having about how to fix this whole
thing
yeah i think it's worth taking a
historical perspective briefly to just
kind of orient everyone to it we don't
have to
um go all the way back to the aliens
who've seen all of civilization but
to just recognize that
for all of human history as far as we're
aware
there were existential risks to
civilizations
and they happened right like there were
civilizations that were
killed in war um that tribes that were
killed in tribal warfare or whatever so
uh people faced existential risk to the
group that they identified with
it's just those were local phenomena
right there it wasn't a fully global
phenomena so an empire could fall
and surrounding empires didn't fall
maybe they came in and filled the space
the first time that we were able to
think about catastrophic risk
not from like a solar flare or something
that we couldn't control but from
something that humans would actually
create at a global level was world war
ii in the bomb because it was the first
time that we had tech big enough that
could
actually mess up everything at a global
level it could mess up habitability we
just weren't powerful enough to do that
before
it's not that we didn't behave in ways
that would have done it we just
only behaved in those ways at the scale
we could affect and
so it's important to get that there's
the entire world before world war
ii where we don't have the ability to
make a non-habitable biosphere
non-inhabitable for us and then there's
world war ii and
the beginning of a completely new phase
where global
human induced catastrophic risk is now a
real thing
and that was such a big deal that it
changed the entire world in a really
fundamental way
which is you know when you study history
it's amazing how big a percentage of
history is studying war right in the
history of wars you said european
history whatever it's generals and wars
and empire expansions and
and so the the major empires near each
other never had really long periods of
time where they weren't engaged in war
or preparation for
or something like that that was humans
don't have a good
precedent in the post tribal phase the
civilization phase of being able to
solve
conflicts without war for very long
world war ii was the first time
where we could have a war that no one
could win
and so the superpowers couldn't fight
again they couldn't do a real kinetic
war they could do
diplomatic wars and cold war type stuff
and they could fight proxy wars through
other countries that didn't have the big
weapons
and so mutually assured destruction and
like coming out of world war ii
we actually realized that nation states
couldn't prevent
world war and so we needed a new type of
supervening government in addition to
nation states which was the whole
bretton woods world the
united nations the world bank the imf
the
globalization trade type agreements
mutually assured destruction
that was how do we have some
coordination beyond
just nation states between them since we
have to stop war between at least the
superpowers
and it was pretty successful given that
we've had like 75 years of no
superpower on superpower war um
we've had lots of proxy wars during that
time we've had you know cold war
and i would say we're in a new phase now
where the bretton woods solution
is basically over almost over can you
describe the
breadth of solution yeah so the bretton
woods
the series of agreements for
how uh the nations would be able to
engage with each other in a solution
other than war um was these igos these
intergovernmental organizations and was
the idea of
globalization since we could have global
effects we needed to be able to think
about things globally
where we had trade relationships with
each other where it would not be
profitable
to war with each other to be more
profitable to actually be able to trade
with each other so our own self-interest
was
you know going to drive our non-more
interest
and so this started to look like and
obviously this this couldn't have
happened
that much earlier either because
industrialization hadn't gotten far
enough to be able to do
massive global industrial supply chains
and ships stuff around
you know quickly but like we were
mentioning earlier almost all the
electronics that we
use today just basic cheap stuff for us
is made on six continents
made in many countries there's no single
country in the world that could actually
make many of the things that we have and
from the
raw material extraction to the plastics
and polymers and the
you know et cetera and so the i the idea
that we made a world that could do that
kind of
trade and create massive gdp growth we
could all work together to be able to
mine natural resources and grow stuff
with the rapid gdp growth there was the
idea that everybody could keep having
more
without having to take each other's
stuff and so that
that was part of kind of the the bretton
woods post world war ii model
the other was that we would be so
economically interdependent that blowing
each other up would never make
sense that worked for a while
now it also brought us
up into planetary boundaries faster the
unrenewable use of resource and turning
those resources into
pollution on the other side of the
supply chain so obviously that faster
gdp growth meant
uh the overfishing of the oceans and the
cutting down of the trees and the
climate change and the
mining toxic mining tailings going into
the water and the
mountaintop removal mining and all those
types of things that's the over
consumption side
of the of the risk that we're talking
about and so the answer of
let's do positive gdp is the answer
rapidly and exponentially obviously
accelerated
the planetary boundary side and that
started to be that that was thought
about for a long time but it started to
be modeled
with the club of rome and limits of
growth um
and it but it's just very obvious to say
if you have a linear materials economy
where you take stuff
out of the earth faster whether it's
fish or trees or or ore
you take or oil you take it out of the
earth faster than it can replenish
itself
and you turn it into trash after using
it for a short period of time you put
the trash in the environment faster than
it can
process itself and there's toxicity
associated with both sides of this
you can't run an exponentially growing
linear materials economy on a finite
planet forever that's not a hard thing
to figure out
and it has to be exponential if there's
an exponentiation in the monetary supply
because of interest and then fractional
reserve banking and to then be able to
keep up with the growing monetary supply
you have to have growth of goods and
services and
so that's that kind of thing that has
happened um
but you also see that when you get these
supply chains that are so interconnected
across the world
you get increased fragility because a
collapse or a problem in one area then
affects the whole world in a much bigger
area as opposed to the issues being
local
right so we got to see with covid and
an issue that started in one part of
china affecting the whole world
so much more rapidly than would have
happened
before bretton woods right before
international travel supply chains
you know that whole kind of thing and
with a bunch of second and third order
effects that people wouldn't have
predicted okay we have to stop
certain kinds of travel because of viral
contaminants but
the countries doing agriculture depend
upon fertilizer they don't produce that
is shipped into them and depend upon
pesticides they don't produce so we got
both
crop failures and crops being eaten by
locusts in scale in northern africa and
iran and things
like that because they couldn't get the
supplies of stuff in so then you get
massive starvation
or future kind of hunger issues because
of supply chain shutdowns
so you get this increased fragility and
cascade dynamics where a small problem
can end up leading to cascade effects
and also we went from two
superpowers with one catastrophe weapon
to now that same catastrophe weapon
is there's more countries
that have it eight or nine countries
that have it and
there's a lot more types of catastrophe
weapons
we now have catastrophe weapons with
weaponized drones that can hit
infrastructure targets with bio with
in fact every new type of tech has
created an arms race
so we have not with the un or the other
kind of intergovernmental organizations
we haven't been able to really do
nuclear deproliferation
we've actually had more countries get
nukes and keep getting faster nukes the
race to
hypersonics and things like that um and
every new type of technology that has
emerged has created an arms race
and so you can't do mutually assured
destruction
with multiple agents the way you can
with two agents two agents it's a
much easier to create a stable nash
equilibrium that's forced
but the ability to monitor and say if
these guys shoot who do i shoot do i
shoot them do i shoot everybody do i
and so you get a three-body problem you
get a very complex type of thing when
you have multiple agents and
multiple different types of catastrophe
weapons including ones that can be much
more easily produced than
nukes are really hard to produce there's
only uranium in a few areas uranium
enrichment is hard
icbms are hard but weaponized drones
hitting smart targets is not so hard
there's a lot of other things where
basically the scale at being able to
manufacture them is going way way down
to where even non-state actors can have
them
and so when we talk about exponential
tech
and the decentralization of exponential
tech what that means is decentralized
catastrophe weapon
capacity and especially in a world of
increasing numbers of people feeling
disenfranchised frantic whatever for
different reasons
so uh i would say
where the bretton woods world doesn't
prepare us to be able to deal with lots
of different agents
having lots of different types of
catastrophe weapons you can't put
mutually sure destruction on
where you can't keep doing growth of
materials economy
in the same way because of hitting
planetary boundaries
and where the fragility dynamics are
actually now their own source of
catastrophic risk
so now we're so like there was all the
world until world war ii and world war
ii is just from uh from a civilization
time scale point of view was just a
second ago
it seems like a long time but it is
really not we get a short period of
relative peace at the level of
superpowers while building up the
military capacity for much much much
worse war the entire time
and then now we're at this new phase
where the things that
allowed us to make it through the
nuclear power are not the same systems
that will let us make it through the
next
stage so what is this next post bretton
woods
how how do we become safe vessels
safe stewards of many different types of
exponential technology
is a key question when we're thinking
about x-risk
okay so and i i'd like to
try to answer the how if you thought a
few ways but first
on the mutually sure destruction
do you give credit to the idea of
two superpowers not blowing each other
up with nuclear weapons
to the simple game theoretic model of
mutually shared destruction
or something you've said previously
this idea of inverse correlation which i
tend to believe between
now if you were talking about tech but i
think it's
maybe broadly true the inverse
correlation between competence and
propensity for destruction
so the better
the the the bigger your weapons not
because you're afraid of
uh mutually assured self-destruction but
because we're human beings and there's a
deep
moral fortitude there that's somehow
aligned with
competence and being good at your job
that like it's very hard to be
a psychopath and be good
at killing at scale
do you share any of that intuition kind
of
i think most people would say that
alexander the great and genghis khan and
napoleon were effective
people that were good at their job uh
that were actually maybe asymmetrically
good
at being able to organize people and do
certain kinds of things
that were pretty oriented towards
certain types of destruction
um or pretty willing to maybe they would
say they were oriented towards empire
expansion but pretty willing to
commit certain acts of destruction in
the name of it what are you worried
about
the genghis khan or
you could argue he's not a psychopath uh
that are you worried about genghis khan
are you worried about hitler or are you
worried about
a terrorist who is
has a very different ethic which is not
even
for uh for it's not trying to preserve
and build
and expand my community it's more about
just the destruction in itself is the
goal i think the thing that you're
looking at that i do agree with is that
there's a psychological disposition
towards
construction and a psychological
disposition more towards destruction
obviously everybody has both and can
toggle between both
and oftentimes one is willing to destroy
certain things we have this idea of
creative destruction right willing to
destroy certain things to create other
things
and utilitarianism and trolley problems
are all about exploring that
space and the idea of war is all about
that
i am trying to create something for our
people and it requires destroying some
other people
sociopathy is a funny topic because it's
possible to have very high fealty to
your in-group
and work on perfecting the methods of
torture to the out group
at the same time because you can
dehumanize and then remove empathy
and i would also say
that there are types so the reason
the thing that gives hope about the
orientation towards construction and
destruction
being a little different in psychologies
is what it takes to build really
catastrophic tech
even today where it doesn't take what it
took to make a new a small group people
could do it
takes still some real technical
knowledge
that required having studied for a while
and some in building capacity
and there's a question of is that
psychologically
inversely correlated with the desire to
damage civilization meaningfully
uh a little bit a little bit i think um
i think a lot i think it's actually i
mean
this is the conversation i had like with
i think offline with dan carlin
which is like it's pretty easy to come
up with
ways that any competent like i can come
up with a lot of ways to hurt a lot of
people
and it's it's pretty easy like i alone
can do it
and like
there's a lot of people as smart or
smarter than me
at least in the creation of explosives
why are we not seeing
more insane mass murder
i i think there's something fascinating
and beautiful
about this yes and it does have to do
with some
deeply pro-social types of
characteristics in humans and
um but when you're dealing with
very large numbers you don't need a
whole lot of a phenomena
and so then you start to say well what's
the probability that x won't happen this
year then won't happen in the next two
years three years four years
and then how many people are doing
destructive things with lower tech and
then how many of them can get access to
higher tech that they didn't have to
figure out how to build
so uh when i can get
commercial tech and maybe i don't
understand tech very well but
i understand it well enough to utilize
it not to create it and i can repurpose
it when we saw that
commercial drone with a homemade
thermite bomb hit the ukraine
ukrainian munitions factory and do the
equivalent of an incendiary bomb
level of damage that's just home tech
that's just simple kind of thing and so
the question is not
what is does it stay being a small
percentage of the population
the question is does can you bind that
phenomena
nearly completely
and especially now when you as you start
to get into bigger things crisper gene
drive
technologies and various things like
that um
can you bind it completely long term
over what period of time not perfectly
though that's the thing i'm trying i'm
trying to say that there is some
let's call it uh that's uh a random word
love that's inherent in
that's core to human nature that's
preventing
destruction at scale and you're saying
yeah but there's a lot of humans there's
going to be eight plus billion
and then there's a lot of seconds in the
day to come up with stuff there's a lot
of pain in the world that can lead to a
distorted view of the world such that
you want to channel that pain into the
destruction
all those kinds of things and it's only
a matter of time that any one individual
can do large damage especially as we
create more and more democratized
decentralized ways to deliver that
damage even if you don't know how to
build the
initial weapon you can but the thing is
it seems like it's a race between
the cheapening of destructive weapons
and the capacity of humans to express
their love
towards each other and it's a race that
so far
i know on twitter you it's not popular
to say but
love is winning okay so what is the
argument that love is going to lose here
against nuclear weapons and biotech and
and ai and uh and drones
okay i'm gonna come at the end of this
to a how love wins so i just want you to
know that that's where i'm oriented
that's the end okay but i'm i'm going to
argue against
why that is a given because it
because it's not a given i don't believe
and i think
this is like a good romantic comedy so
you're going to create drama right now
but it will end in a happy evening well
it's because it's only a happy ending if
we actually understand the issues well
enough and take responsibility to shift
it
do i believe like there's a reason why
there's so much more dystopic sci-fi
than pro-topic sci-fi in the in the some
proto-big sci-fi
usually requires magic is because
or at least magical tech right dilithium
crystals and warp drives and stuff
because it's very hard to imagine
people like the people we have been in
the history books
with exponential type
technology and power that don't
eventually blow themselves up
that make good enough choices as
stewards of their environment and their
comments and
and each other and etc so like it's
easier to think of scenarios where we
blow ourselves up than it is to think of
scenarios where we avoid every single
scenario where we blow ourselves up and
when i say blow ourselves up i also i
mean the environmental versions
the terrorist versions the war versions
the cumulative externalities
versions um
can i and i'm sorry if i'm interrupting
your flow of thought
but why is it easier is it could it be a
weird psychological thing where we
either was just more capable to
visualize explosions and destruction
and then the sicker thought which is
like we kind of enjoy
for some weird reason thinking about
that kind of stuff even though we
wouldn't
actually act on it it's almost like some
weird uh
like i love playing shooter games you
know uh first person shooters
and like especially if it's like
murdering zombie and doom
you're shooting demons i played one of
my favorite games
diablo is like slashing through
different monsters and the screaming and
pain and the hellfire
and then i go out into the real world uh
to eat my coconut ice cream and i'm all
about love
so like i can we trust our ability to
visualize
how all it all goes to [ __ ] as an actual
rational way of thinking
i think it's a fair question to say to
what degree is there just
kind of perverse fantasy and
morbid exploration and whatever else
that happens in our imagination
uh but i don't think that's the whole of
it
i think there is also a reality to the
combinatorial possibility space
and the difference in the probabilities
that there's a lot of ways i could try
to put
the 70 trillion cells of your body
together that don't make you
there's not that many ways i can put
them together that make you there's a
lot of ways i could try to connect the
organs together that make some weird
kind of
group of organs on the on a desk but
that doesn't actually make a functioning
human and and you can kill an adult
human in a second but you can't get one
in a second takes
20 years to grow one and a lot of things
to happen right i could destroy this
building
in a couple minutes with demolition
but it took a year or a couple years to
build it there is
uh there is just an example
it's not he doesn't mean it there's a
there's a gradient where entropy is
easier
and there's a lot more ways to put a set
of things together that don't work than
the few that really do produce higher
order synergies
and so
when we look at a history of war and
then we look at
exponentially more powerful warfare and
arms race that drives that in all these
directions
and when we look at a history of
environmental destruction and
exponentially more powerful tech that
makes exponential externalities
multiplied by the total number of agents
that are doing it in the cumulative
effects
there's a lot of ways the whole thing
can break like a lot of different ways
and for it to get ahead it has to have
none of those happen
and so there's just a probability space
where it's easier to imagine that thing
so
what so to say how do we have a protopic
future we have to say well
one criteria must be that it avoids all
of the catastrophic risks
so can we understand can we inventory
all the catastrophic risks can we
inventory the patterns of human behavior
that give rise to them
and could we try to solve for that and
could we have that be
the essence of the social technology
that we're thinking about to be able to
guide bind and direct the new physical
technology because so far our physical
technology
like we were talking about the genghis
khans and like that that obviously use
certain kinds of
physical technology and armaments and
also social technology and
unconventional warfare
for a particular set of purposes but we
have things that don't look like warfare
like rockefeller and standard oil
and it looked like a constructive
mindset
to be able to uh bring this new energy
resource
to the world and it did and the second
order effects of that
are climate change
and all of the oil spills that have
happened and will happen
and all of the wars in the middle east
over the oil that have been there
and the massive political [ __ ]
and human life issues that are
associated with it and
on and on right and so
it's also not just
the orientation to construct a thing can
have a narrow focus on what i'm trying
to construct but be affecting a lot of
other things through second and
third-order effects i'm not taking
responsibility for
and you you often another and another
tangent
mentioned second third and fourth order
effects
and the order and and skating which is
really fascinating like starting with
the third order
plus it gets really interesting
because we we don't we don't even
acknowledge like the second order
effects
right but like thinking because those it
could mat
it could get bigger and bigger and
bigger in ways we're not anticipating
so how do we make those so it sounds
like part of the
part of the thing that you're thinking
through in terms of a solution
how to create an anti-fray agile a
resilient society
is to make explicit
acknowledge understand the externalities
the second order
third order fourth order and the order
effects
how do we start to think about those
effects
yeah the war application is harm we're
trying to cause or that we're aware
we're causing
right um the externality is harm that at
least supposedly we're not aware we're
causing or at minimum it's not our
intention
right maybe we're either totally unaware
of it or we're aware of it but
it is a side effect of what our
intention is it's not the intention
itself
there are catastrophic risks from both
types the direct application
of increased technological power to a
rivalrous intent
which is going to cause harm for some
out group for some in group to win
but the out group is also working on
growing the tech and if they don't lose
completely they
reverse engineer the tech upregulator
come back with more
capacity so there's the exponential tech
arms race
side of in-group out-group rivalry using
exponential tech that is one set of
risks
and the other set of risks
the application of exponentially more
powerful tech
not intentionally to try and beat an out
group but to try to achieve some goal
that we have but to produce a second and
third order effects
that do have harm to the commons to
other people to
environment to other groups uh
that might actually be bigger problems
than the problem we were originally
trying to solve with the thing we were
building
when facebook was building a dating app
and then building a social app where
people could tag pictures
they weren't trying to build a democracy
destroying app
that would maximize time on site
as part of its ad model through ai
optimization of a news feed to the thing
that made people spend most time on site
which is usually them being
limbically hijacked more than something
else which ends up appealing to people's
cognitive biases and group identities
and creates no sense of shared reality
they weren't trying to do that but it
was a second order effect
and it's a pretty [ __ ] powerful
second order effect
and a pretty fast one because the rate
of tech is obviously
able to get distributed to much larger
scale much faster and
with a bigger jump in terms of total
vertical capacity then that's what it
means to get to the verticalizing part
of an exponential curve
so um just like we can see
that oil had these second order
environmental effects and also social
and political effects
war and so much of the whole
like the total amount of oil used is
has a proportionality to total global
gdp
and that's why we have this you know the
petrodollar and um
and so the the oil thing also had the
externalities of a major aspect of what
happened with military industrial
complex and things like that
so but we can see the same thing with
with
more current technologies with facebook
and google and
and other things so i don't think we can
run
and the more powerful the tech is we
build it for
reason x whatever reason x is maybe x is
three things maybe it's one thing
right we we're doing the oil thing
because we want to make
cars because it's a better method of
individual transportation we're building
the facebook thing because we're going
to
connect people socially in a personal
sphere but
it it intersects with it interacts with
complex systems
with ecologies economies psychologies
cultures and so it has effects on other
than the thing we're intending
some of those effects can end up being
negative effects but because this
technology
if if we make it to solve a problem it
has to overcome the problem the
problem's been around for a while it's
going to overcome in a short period of
time so it usually has
greater scale greater rate of magnitude
in some way
that also means that the externalities
that it creates might be bigger problems
and you can say well but then that's the
new problem humanity will innovate its
way out of that
well i don't think that's paying
attention to the fact that we can't keep
up with exponential curves
like that nor do finite spaces allow
exponential externalities forever
and this is why a lot of the smartest
people thinking about this are
thinking well no i think we're totally
screwed and
unless we can make a benevolent ai
singleton that rules all of us
um you know guys like bostrom and and
others
uh thinking in those directions because
they're like how do
humans try to do multi-polarity
and make it work and i i have a
different answer
of what i think it looks like that does
have more to do with the
love but some applied social tackle line
alignment
because i have a bunch of really dumb
ideas i prefer to uh
i'd like to hear i'd like to hear some
of them first
you